foreign
[Music]
and welcome to today's webinar antibody
Discovery by single B cell screening on
Beacon I am Cassie saltman of lab roots
and I'll be your moderator for today's
event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by labroots and brought to you
by xenobiological
to learn more visit xenobiological.com
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click Send we'll answer
as many questions as we have time for at
the end of the presentation
you may also submit any technical issues
here as well if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation
I'd like to now welcome our speaker Amy
Shang technical account manager
xenobiological
Amy you may now begin your presentation
welcome everybody I'm Amy Shin the
technical account manager of
xenobiological
welcome to this webinar in the next 40
minutes I will walk you through the
development of monoclonal antibody so
single B cell sorting based on Beacon
platform
the webinar will cover the following
sections first B cell differentiation
and the development
second we will talk about various
antibody screening platforms then we
will get to know what is Beacon platform
the last we will discuss couple of case
studies using the beacon platform for
antibody screening
Visa differentiation and development
B cells are the only immune cells in the
body that can produce antibodies
Bissell differentiation and development
occurs in two distinctive stages
development in the central immune organs
which can be simply described as the
following sequential process common
lymphoid progenitor cells to Pro B cells
to pre-b cells followed by Immature B
cells
and then mature b cells
this process depends on the bone marrow
microenvironment and involves Gene
Arrangement BCR expression and the
negative selection
the second stage is the development in
peripheral immune organs where the
mature b cells migrate into the
peripheral immune organs and are
activated by specific antigens with the
help of T cells
this activated B cells undergo profile
Liberation and differentiation thereby
forming germinal centers
mature b cells differentiate into plasma
cells and memory B cells
plasma cells are terminally
differentiated B cells whose main
function is produced antibodies minor B
cells however can survive for a long
time in the body upon restermination by
the same antigen they can rapidly
differentiate into plasma cells and
produce antibodies therefore triggering
the immune response
with a background of how antibodies are
produced let's take a look how
antibodies are deliberately developed on
various platforms
hybridoma technology has been around for
almost 50 years since its invention in
1975.
as of now hybrid almost still the most
commonly used technique for antibody
production
outlined as follow
first single cell suspensions are
prepared from the immune organ usually
the spleen of an immunized animal and
fused with myeloma cells
common infusion methods include Peg
mediated fusion and electrofusion
the latter of which shows higher Fusion
efficiency
three types of cells exist in the Cell
fusion system
unfused spleen cells myanoma cells and
diffused hybridoma
this hypodermas formed by the B cell the
myeloma Fusion are obtained by HTT
selection and then screened with Elisa
to obtain positive clones
further dilution and screening yield
immortalized monoclonal hypodermas that
stably produce single antibodies
the disadvantages of hypoderma cells are
it is a well-established methodology
with very high successful rate
um each functionality and Affinity
screening can be carried out along the
experiment for screening and selecting
the ideal clones
the cost is relatively low since there
is no special equipment is required
however there are disadvantages of these
platforms
the first of all is that the Cell fusion
efficiency might be low
the success rate of fusion is merely one
in a thousand even for Electro Fusion
stays suitable myeloma cell lines for
Cell fusion are not always available
thus there is a limitation in antibody
species we can develop
long life cycle it can generally take
two to three months from Cell fusion to
obtaining positive clause
second generation of antibody
development use phage display
it is another commonly used antibody
screening Technologies in this technique
antibody genes fragments are cloned in
vitro and inserted into the structuring
of the phage coated products
antibodies are then displayed on the
surface of the phage the expression of
fusion proteins this step is called
phage Library Construction
antigens are then used to screen for
phage library for specific monoclonal
antibodies a stepped known as bio
panning
the main steps for constructing a faged
libraries are as follows we extract the
tissue RNA and derived the cdna by
reverse transcription
we obtain the antibody light in heavy
chains by PCR and join them and
incorporate them into phage genes
we transfect the engineered bacteria
with phages to amplify features for
antibody display
specific phage screening is based on
antibody antigen binding the target
antigen is
immobilized on the solid phase and then
incubated with the phage library for
period of time
Unbound free phages are then moved by
washing and the bone phases are eluted
by enzymatic digestion using like
trypsin or acetyl base
the eluded phages are used to infect
host the cells for amplification and
absorption illusion process is repeated
after three to five rounds wages that
bind specifically to antigens are
obtained
advantages of phage display is that its
application in a wide range of species
the antibody Library can be derived from
immunized animals such as mice rabbits
alpacas and chickens
antibody produced by an organism after
vaccination or microbial infection or
even samples from patients with
autoimmune diseases
second is that fully human antibody
libraries are available and the cost is
relatively low
the disadvantages of this platform is
its sustainability to the quality and
the size of the FH Library
there is limited Affinity because most
of antibodies in the library have not
undergone in Vivo Affinity maturation
leading to The Limited Affinity of
antibodies derived from phage display
technology
third now natural antibodies pairing
light and heavy chains genes are
randomly recombined in the library using
the Affinity of obtained antibodies
might be compromised
single B cell technology is a recently
developed technique to produce
monoclonal antibodies rapidly
I mean this technique antigen specific B
cells are isolated from the peripheral
blood or immune organs via fluorescence
activated cell sorting also known as
facts or Beacon technology
specific antibody sequences are then
derived by single cell PCR
the antibody sequence is incorporated
into an expression vector and the
monoclonal antibodies obtained by
antibody expression and purification
the advantages of single B Technologies
include that it is not limited by
species actually it has applications in
a wide range of species
natural cognates The Edge and VL pairing
is preserved
third it has short development cycle
single B cell Source screening is fast
and a large number of candidates can be
screened within a day
lastly antibodies from single B platform
generally show higher Affinity than
phage display
single B cell technology screens for
memory B cells or plasma cells which
have undergone Affinity maturation in
Vivo giving rise to a high antibody
affinity
of course this platform has its
limitation
single cell sorting equipment is
required thus higher cost
the following is a comparison of the two
techno techniques based on single B cell
technology
fluorescence activated cell sorting
facts and the beacon
fluorescence activated cell sorting can
be used to screen antibodies from Human
mouse rabbits
Etc it sorts out the memory B cells not
a lot of functional validation can be
done during the screening and sorting
process and the throughput is about 10
000 cells per second
for Beacon platform due to a lack of
plasma cell isolation reagents only
Mouse plus plasma cell isolation is
available currently
as we mentioned the facts is based on
the screening of specific memory B cells
memory B cells are identified by binding
of fluorescence labeled antigens to bcrs
expressed on the memory B cell membrane
if the expression and purification of
the antigens are challenging it will be
difficult to sort B cells by facts
the beacon platform is based on plasma
cell screening plasma cells which
secrete the antibodies have high content
of intracellular antibody RNA making it
easier to obtain antibody genes
for antigens that are difficult to
express and purify weaken case screen
antibodies using recombinant cell lines
regarding the throughput of Beacon it
can run four chips a total 80 000 cells
per round
both of these platforms are high
throughput platforms
Beacon is an automatic device with
functions of cell incubator style safety
cabinet fluorescence microscope and
automated robotic arm which integrates
microfluidics signal detection and might
induce the Technologies
based on the morphology and the
fluorescence characterization of cells
be consistent can be used to conduct
cell isolation cell culture real-time
detection of cell secretion and
Multiplex detection directly on the chip
in addition the target cells can also be
exported through Beacon system
be consistent is highly automatic and
less dependent operators
let's take a look of the chip which are
the core components of Beacon system
operations such as cell culture cell
screening and cell export are performed
on the chips
each fee consistent can have four chips
run simultaneously
each ship consists of horizontal
channels and vertical Nano pins
the Nano pins are connected by channels
depending on the number of the nanopans
chips can be divided into various
specifications such as 11k 14k or 20K
for example the 14k cheap can have 10
channels and more than 14
000 Nano pants and the volume of each
nanopan is less than one nanometer
doing the cell culture the cultural
media will flow through the channel at
relative low speed so the nutrients in
the media can enter the nanopans from
the channels through the diffusion
at the same time the wastes produced by
cell metabolism can also diffuse into
the channels from the nanopans and then
circulate out of the chip
however larger particles such as cells
or
microbeads can remain steel and not
affected by the mobile phase when they
enter the nanopans so the known term
Dynamic cell culture observation and
Analysis can be realized
because of the volume of nanopan is in
nanoliter 10 000 volume of a single wear
of the 96 well plate the concentration
of the cell secretion is relative High
even at the Single Cell level
and therefore the Single Cell level
detection can be easily achieved
the antibody screening through Beacon
platforms generally includes five steps
cell import cell screening validation
tests Target cell exports and antibody
Gene amplification among them cell
import validation test and Export are
accomplished by the beacon system
become platforms use plasma cells for
antibody screening
for which the plasma cells needs to be
enriched from the lymphoid tissues at
first
there are usually two methods for plasma
cell enrichment fluorescence activated
cell sorting and magnetic beads based
sorting
compared with fluorescence activated
cell sorting the magnetic bead sorting
is faster and less damaging to cells in
view of this magnetic deep space
resorting is usually preferred
the principle of cell sorting using
immunomagnetic beads is as follows based
on The Binding characteristics of cell
service antigen and specific antibody
coupled metallic beads when there is
external magnetic field
the cells coupled to the magnetic beads
through the antibodies are absorbed and
retained in the field
and then the target cells can be
isolated
using differently labeled cells magnetic
beads sorting generally can be divided
into two categories positive screening
or selection and negative selection
in positive selection the target cells
are obtained while in negative
selections the non-target cells are
removed
taking mouse as example
the phenotype of mouse plasma cells is
cd138 positive and B20 negative
we generally use a combined selection
methods that integrates both positive
and negative selections that is the B20
positive cells can be first removed by
negative selection and then
cd138 positive cells can be obtained by
positive selections after two sequential
rounds of positive and the negative
selections the purity of plasma cells
can reach 90 percent and the cell
variability can be maintained at 98
percent
normally we can obtain approximately 1
million plasma cells from an immunized
Mouse
after completing plasma cell isolation
the plasma cells can be imported into
the cheap
firstly the plasma cells are imported
into the channels and unified
distributed
uniformed distributed
next the plasma cells in the channels
will be put into the number pens using
optical Electro positioning oep
technology through Beacon system and
meanwhile the Redundant cells in the
channel will be flushed out of the chip
finally be consistent with automatically
run the cell culture mode
doing cell import the concentration of
imported cells should be paid special
attention to if the cell concentration
is too high there will be cell adhesion
leading to multiple cells in one
nanopane and the production of
polyclonal antibodies on the other hand
if the cell concentration is too low
some nanopans will be empty resulting in
the decreased utilization of the chip
here in this video
it shows a nicely distributed chip with
majority of the Nano pins filled with
only one single B cell
after B cells are imported the target
cells can be screened based on the
principle of antigen antibody binding
the antigen coated magnetic beads and
fluorescent secondary antibodies are
imported into the channels
if the antibodies produced by the cells
in the nanopaths are the specific Target
antibodies they will bind to the beads
and the fluorescence secondary
antibodies
we can can catch the fluorescent speeds
by taking multiple snapshots and the
dynamic fluorescence generation process
can also be absorbed simultaneously
then the positive clones can be screened
out through these rounds
since the plasma cells in the nanopans
with fluorescence bees are just the
positive clones capable of producing
specific antibodies
here we can show in see in this video
the nanopans harboring the positive
clones emit fluorescence signals that
can be recognized by the beaker
in Beacon system we can also check
cross-rex species reactivity by
replacing the antigen coated on the
magnetic beads with those from other
species
we just need to change the
protein and validate in the same way
generally the antigen coated on the
magnetic beads or recombinant proteins
and the conformations are not completely
consistent with natural proteins this
might lead to situations where the
antibody screened within recombinant
antigen might not necessarily bind to
Natural proteins besides for some
antigens
that are difficult to express and purify
in vitro such as gpcr and we it's
difficult for us to obtain their obtain
recombinant antigens with stable
structures
then we will use stable recombinant cell
lines instead of the beads for antibody
screening
there are two methods to perform ligand
blocking validation the first is to
block the antigen coded on the beads
with ligands to form stable composite
microbeads
and then import these beads and
fluorescent secondary antibodies into
the channel
if the plasma cells in the nanopins
produce antibody
blocking antibodies these antibodies
cannot bind to the antigens on the beads
and then the fluorescence secondary
antibodies also cannot be indirectly
mixed to the beads through a specific
binding therefore resulting no
fluorescence of beads
on the contrary the beads will become
fluorescent if the plasma cells
producing non-blocking antibodies
second way is that the antigen coated
beads are imported into nanopans so that
antibody produced by the plasma cells
combined to the antigen first
and then the fluorescence labeled and
ligands are imported
similarly if fluorescence can be
captured into the nanopane the
non-blocking antibodies are produced
conversely the blocking antibodies are
produced as shown in this figure among
the four nanopans marked in the blue and
the red fluorescence was detected in
those two blue Nano pants so the plasma
cells in these nanopans produce
non-blocking antibodies while in no
fluorescence were detected in those two
red nanopins indicating the plasma cells
in these locations produce blocking
antibodies
after target clones are confirmed
through validation tests the target
cells can be exported the export is also
performed by using the oep technology
through the beacon system the cells can
be pushed out of the Nano pins and
flushed into the molecule phase you can
shown over here
it is worth noting that in addition to
export target cells be consistent can
also perform reverse transcription
reaction directly on the chip that is
directly obtaining the cdna sequence of
the target antibody but the cost will be
relative higher
now let's take a look of couple case
studies of antibody developed on Beacon
system
enter ID antibody is an antibody that
can specifically recognize a variable
region of the antibody which is widely
used in the pharmacokinetic PK and
thermocol dynamic studies PD of antibody
drugs during the drug development
for example in PK studies enter ID
antibodies are used to detect the levels
of antibody drugs in Vivo in addition
anti-id antibody can be used as positive
control antibodies for ligand binding
assays and antibody blocking assays
enter ID antibodies can be divided into
two types antigen blocking type
The Binding side of enter ID antibody is
exactly the same as that of antibody
drug and at Target protein which can be
used to detect the level of free
antibody drugs in Vivo the other type is
the antigen non-blocking type
The Binding of the antibody anti-id
antibody to the antibody drug does not
block The Binding of antibody drug to
the pro and Target protein which can be
used to detect the total amount of
antibody drugs in the body including
free and Target protein Bond antibody
drugs
how anti-id antibodies are developed
doing the screening of enter ID
antibodies The Binding to antibody drugs
needs to be validated and excluding The
Binding to regular human IGG
The compactive Binding to the Target
protein also needs to be validated that
is whether the antibody produced is
competitive or non-competitive needs to
be determined
we can
complete the about three validation
tests on the beacon system to obtain the
target positive clones
through the rapid immunization
Technologies from cyanobiological we can
complete the immunization tests our mice
to obtain plasma cells within two weeks
then through the beacon the validation
of binding to antibody drugs binding to
human IGG and competitive binding can be
completed within one day
and then target cells can be obtained
and explored
exported
next the amplification of the target
antibody genes can be completed within
one week
finally expression and purification of
the antibody binding test by Elisa and
competitiveness validation can be
completed within two weeks the screening
of positive clones only takes about 35
days which is completed in nearly two
months earlier than that by traditional
hybrid Dogma technology
this shows the statistics from one of
our case
after the tissues of the mice simulized
with antibody drug was harvested cell
isolation was performed to obtain
humanized plasma cells a total of 11
978 clones were imported into Beacon
chips and 772 clones were screened that
confirmed to bind to the antibody drug
of which
151 clones did not want to human IGG
after competitiveness validation with
the target protein a total of 56 clones
produced competitive antibodies
and 97 clones produced non-competitive
antibodies
some positive clones were selected for
subsequent antibody Gene amplification
and antibody expression and purification
by the validation of the purified
antibodies an anti-id antibody that
could bind to the full length antibody
drop but not the human IGG was obtained
sort of competitive inhibition rate
tests non-competitive and competitive
anti-d antibodies could be further
obtained
protein modification refers to the group
modification of protein after
translation
there are protein modifications such as
escalation
ubiquitination methylation and
phosphorylation
among which for simulation is the most
common and important post-translational
modification
the screening of phosphorylated
antibodies can be carried out through
the beacon platform which can realize
multiplexer detection with a short
screening cycle
post-related polypeptides are used
usually selected as immunogens doing the
screening of positive clones
phosphorylated and non-force related
antigens will be used for compound
screening respectfully and then clones
that are positive for binding to
phospholated polypeptide and negative
for binding to non-phosphorally peptide
will be obtained
foreign
four hundred clones were imported and
109 clones were positive for binding to
the forcefully polypeptide of which 63
were negative for binding to the
non-phosphorylated polypeptide that is
63 clones where the phosphorylated
specific clones we need
City 47 is the natural immunosuppressive
molecule that is widely expressed on the
surface of normal cells by binding to
SRP Alpha on the surface of a
macrophages it activates the protective
Pathways and inhibits some
phagocytosis of my macrophages
however in order to avoid the cytosis of
a macrophages some cancer cells also
imitate the normal cells to express cd47
thereby inhibiting the activity of
macrophages
blocking The Binding of cd47 to SRP
Alpha by City 47 antibody is an
immunotherapy for cancer
after the optimization of its FC region
the city for December antibody combined
to the FC receptors of emu cells thereby
triggering ADCC CDC or adcp effects
which can boost the tumor cell killing
of immuno cells however due to the high
expression of ct47 on the surface of
normal cells especially
erythrocytes and platelets earlier cd47
antibody drugs generally caused severe
anemia in clinical trials
the new generation of cd47 antibody
therapy focuses on the production of
fusion antibodies such as antibodies
fused to SRP Alpha
and optimization of dosing regimens and
antibody structures
in our case study cd47 antibodies were
screened using Beacon platform after
screening there were a total 331
positive clones that could bind to both
antigens and natural cells by further
expression and purification a total 108
antibodies were positive in realized
tests
and 73 antibodies could block The
Binding of cd47 to SRP Alpha
next the validation of The Binding of
these antibodies to tumor cells and your
visual sites were performed and it was
found that two of the antibodies were
weakly bind to erythrocytes and normally
bind to tumor cells
through Affinity validation it was to
find that the Affinity of this
antibodies screened by Beacon were
almost at the same level of the
reference antibodies how about use
Deacon to develop antibodies targeting
virus
as the World Health Organization
declared that monkey pox outbreak a
public health emergency of international
concern cyanobiological developed the
antigen and antibody reagents to be used
in monkeypox virus studies in the first
place
the a29 protein of monkeypox virus is
homologous to the a27 protein of
vaccinia virus with a stronger
immunogenicity
he was reported that age 29 protein of
monkeypox virus is a target of the
monkey pox virus specific monocomer
antibody and a key Target of
neutralizing antibodies
we use the recombinant
a2a9 protein of monkeypox virus as the
immunogen and completed the immunization
of mice by rapid immunization platforms
from xenobiological
321 positive plants were screened out by
the beacon platforms and after
expression purification and subsequent
Western blotting and Elisa testing
several antibodies that can bind to the
age-29 proteins with high affinities
were successfully obtained
so no biological is the One-Stop in
international religion supplier and
service provider we have more than 6500
proteins and 14 000 antibodies online
we provide recombinant protein and
antibody expression and polyclonal and
monoclonal antibody development
our facility is ISO certified and our
users in more than 90 countries have
generated over 10 000 citations relative
to our products in high impact factor
journals
we provide High through food production
and screening services as well as gram
level of scale up Productions to
generate proteins or antibodies for our
customers
moreover we provide Productions to make
antibodies in various formats such as
Fab sov bhh by specific to help
researchers to answer specific questions
to better facilitate our customers
xenobiological has a Global Response
presence we have offices in four
countries and multiple production
locations please let us know if there is
anything we can be a help for you and
thank you
foreign
thank you Amy for your informative
presentation we will now start the live
q a portion of the webinar if you have a
question you'd like to ask please do so
now just click on the ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
we'll answer as many of your questions
as we have time for
let's get started our first question is
what type of research can the beacon and
facts platform be applied to how is it
helping Advance research
um yes so Beacon and fax platforms can
be used for many many different types of
research I'm actually besides the
antibody Discovery as we discussed just
now Beacon can be used to develop
cell-based products for example like the
stable cell lines that can produce
proteins with very high tider and this
development can be done with fast speed
and low cost
compared to the traditional methods of
course Beacon can also be used to
characterize T Cell functionality by
performing barriers and many kind of
different functional assays and as for
facts it is a more established platform
it can it has been you widely used to
identify and sort out and also enrich
the desired cell populations in many
different biological samples so so it
can be used for immuno typing DNA cell
cycle tumor ploidy
membrane potential ion flux cell
variability and
Etc at least you can go on forever and
thanks for the high throughput features
on both platforms the cost and the time
for developing cell lines drugs are
greatly reduced
thank you our next question is how does
a client choose between the hyperdoma
platform and the single B sorting
um yes that's actually a question we got
a lot
um when researchers come to us and ask
which platform will suit their research
spatter
um both platforms can develop and
provide good clones so for hyperdoma
platform
um you know it is very straightforward
and there is no need of special
equipment so basically we can perform
that in in all the labs and therefore
the cost is lower it is perfect for
getting a small to medium amount of
clones with high affinity and also once
you obtain the positive clones and later
say if you run out of the antibody you
want to get more of it you just need to
pull out the cells and do a regular
culture and purification
um however the screening working the
hybridoma platforms might get
overwhelming if extensive screenings or
counter screenings are required
um so for for examples
um there are some researchers that want
to focus on very specific isoform and
however this targeted isoform shares
quite large homology with other isoforms
that he or she might want to avoid in
this case then we will need to perform a
lot of counter screening which hyperdoma
platforms may not be able to provide and
in this way single B sorting will be
perfect in this case
because it can perform very um a quite
High capability of screening in other
case
um scientists like they want to a large
number of different clones say 200 or
300 then targeting the same protein to
ensure they can get a good diversity of
clones so this work might be again two
tedious and Nancy hybridoma platforms
but single B sorting will be able to
help usually I I schedule a meeting with
the researchers to understand their
needs specifications timelines and
budget around the antibody development
project and work with our team so that
we can propose a suitable platforms for
them
okay fantastic our next question here is
what is the ratio of positive clones in
sorted cells and how do we increase it
the ratio of positive ones among the
whole sort of cells is approximately 30
to 40 percent
um it depends on the serum titer
conditions of sorted cells and results
of sorting and you know the following
PCR and recombinant expression so
unfortunately there are lots of the
Clones might happen in each of the steps
I just mentioned so to increase the
ratio and the number of positive clones
we get in the end it is it is very very
important to make sure that the serum
title is good enough to start with
um since if the so imagine if the title
is low the amount of positive clones and
also the quality of clones are not
expected to be high so for tighter if
it's for rabbit we set a standard of at
least 25 000 dilution and and for Mouse
16
000 dilution and at PCR and recombinant
expression stage it is very important to
have stable systems that can yield a
good sequencing and pairing and and
antibody expression and purification
perfect thank you it looks like we have
time for one more question
what are the challenges with antibody
development usually and how are they
overcome
the main challenges of traditional
platforms are time through through food
and high dependence on operators the
hybridoma platforms like we just talked
about it takes longer time and a lot of
manpower to perform fusion and screening
and the success rate heavily depends on
hands
sometimes if the experiments was not on
the optimum condition then whole process
could be roomed and time wasted and for
phage display platform compared to the
facts and Beacon has more steps and also
require higher energy to handle
experiments so it does not also it does
not produce native pairing right so for
facts and Beacon they are able to solve
these problems and produce a larger
clone number with validated attributes
within shorter time and with lower
dependence on whoever's performing The
Experiment
thank you Amy for your time today and
your important research we would also
like to thank lab roots and our sponsors
xenobiological for underwriting today's
educational webcast
before we go I'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions
we did not have time for today and those
submitted during the on-demand period
will be addressed by the speaker via the
contact information you provided at the
time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand lab
Roots will alert you via email when it's
available for replay we encourage you to
share that email with your colleagues
who may have missed today's live event
until next time goodbye